In the very first episode of NCIS, titled
"Yankee White," the death of a Marine on Air
Force One triggers a mess of jurisdictional
complications.
The question this episode raises is who claims
jurisdiction over the death of a Naval commander
who dies on Air Force One?
Do Gibbs and his team have any right to fly
away with the president's plane in order to
hold such jurisdiction?
First, let's break the events of the episode
down: The second the president walks off the
plane, the Secret Service loses jurisdiction,
and it gets handed off to the FBI, hence FBI
Agent Fornell's presence at the crime scene.
The Secretary of the Navy instructs that,
since NCIS has a horse in the race in the
form of a dead officer, they would have jurisdiction
to take custody of the body in the real world.
However, does that really give them the right
to snatch the president's plane to ensure
they keep custody?
And if they can't take the plane, how is it
that we never hear about anyone getting in
trouble for that stunt thereafter?